it's time for et social study a quick  look at what the stars are posting  online I thought it was important that  you be the first to know Janet Jackson  shared the first ever photo of her  adorable baby boy Issa on Instagram  right after naptime looking too cute  that was fun without me all right blake  lively shared a few saucy snaps to  instagram that hubby Ryan Reynolds shot  of her while the two enjoyed a romantic  getaway and Serena Williams showed off  her toned beach bod in a bright yellow  bikini just because duh someone else who  isn't afraid of yellow kylie jenner she  debuted her highlighter locks while  kicking it at Coachella over the weekend  meanwhile Salma Hayek mourned the loss  of her beloved dog blue paying tribute  to the pup on Instagram writing in part  I understand he's in a better place but  my eyes cry anyway  you  [Music]